everything beyond about ten feet is out
of focus correct that it's always at eye
level and that everything is blurry and
that's intentional so that we are not
really seeing all of his world because
it remains objective and it's clearly a
very specific choice you make it's it's
about the individual experience of the
camp so that the in cinematic terms find
a way to to convey to the audience the
limitations of the individual something
that I think has never been really
suggested or shown that this can dis
kind of limitations in the during the
Holocaust we always have this distance
we always have the post for point of
view but what if we went back to the
here and now that so that's why we we
actually established guidelines for
ourselves for with the Scimitar refer to
really to what what we did and what we
wanted to do and what we wanted to avoid
you know we wanted to remain at eye
level we wanted to to void all kinds of
of temptation to make beauty out of
human suffering so it really to be as
Ron but as possible in this film I know
you haven't you probably have done as
much music as you have done a crane what
was you're looking for in your soul and
how did you guys come together I knew
him from before I met him 10 years
before and we became friends and when I
started casting for this film although I
didn't know which for which part
actually but I knew I wanted him in the
film so I'm at some point we made him
try he lived in New York now he's
originally from Hungary visa but he had
to travel to Hungary to to have some
editions with us for the second part
which is the a bruh abraham's part and
then he started we asked him to to be
solved the main character as well in
certain configurations with other actors
and he was just very
you know convincing and and it seemed
that he was in his you know and in his
you know in his existence in his form of
just just behaving in and and reflected
so much of what I had in mind and he
became alive you know that that was the
that was the the first step
do you remember those auditions and when
you went from playing Abraham to playing
Saul and Laszlo is a very principled and
disciplined filmmakers so we really
didn't want 92014 somehow in this movie
whatsoever let it be a body language or
the way I speak you know so so we really
without going right to the lines there
was just some very basic conversation
taking place for a good while
I think last who knew that I am you know
deeply connected with the subject matter
and I didn't have to go through you know
the regular reading assignments I guess
some other actors had to do but I did my
homework of course on his own there come
on do especially you know what were they
about to and I did their lives look like
not so much their thoughts and feelings
but their lives in the most precise way
but what were they doing where when how
and I did not have the chance to meet
any former Sonderkommando members before
the shooting but I was privileged to
meet one of them a couple weeks ago here
in LA who is in Los Angeles right here
couple miles from here a greek jew who
arrived in december to Auschwitz my me
imagine a below zero weather for a Greek
person from Thessaloniki so you know
they were promised to to have a better
lives heated environment you know stuff
like that so he raised his hand but he
never voluntarily wanted to be part of
the extermination process obviously
so in any case I did do remember this
improvisations I don't know how or when
did not know decided to offer me the
lead role there's a reference in the
story to Saul saying I'll tell them
where the stories where the stories
you're writing or buried or the letters
you're writing are buried was their
existing source material from some of
the people who died there about what
their experiences were like and with
their specific stories and information
about the Sutter commandos and their
lives what with what was the reference
you found yeah that was the point of
departure of the film when I first read
the the so called Scrolls of Auschwitz
the right things by the members of the
zonal commando these were made by the
Sonderkommando members in the middle of
the extermination process you know they
would write in secret and put put those
writing into the into the ground and
some of those writings were were found
after the war by the way the historian
told me that probably 90% of the
writings have never been found so it's
still out it's it's still full of
writings about stuff about their
individual lives and and the experience
of the Holocaust and it was read it was
a great shock and for me when I read it
because it transported me as a reader
into the middle of the extermination and
and so some of the writings are very
factual some are some some are more
porrik or more literature like but but
very you know in the eye I don't know
why these writings are not really well
known but they're an incredible
incredible angle to look at the
extermination and I wanted to find a way
to do to immerse the viewer in this film
and and be transported as the writings
transport also the viewers to the center
for people don't know you have you been
teaching high school children Jewish
history correct genetic studies was it
important to you that this move
we not be about survival and heroism but
it be about truth and the people who
died tremendously important I mean we
know that two out of three Jews were
murdered in Europe by dollar cost and
all these movies I've seen they always
always about the low-key third the one
who made it so I've been waiting for
someone for a long time to be able to
adjust this you know make a movie about
the first two because every survival was
due to systematic error no one meant to
survive so I understand that this is a
dark topic but it but I I've grown tired
and uncomfortable frustrated frankly to
see all these movies somehow to reassure
the audience that that the Holocaust can
be integrated into the continuum of
history and I I found when I was there
first time 19 years oldest to the
University student in Poland and I
visited the camp for the very first time
I right away knew that something has
ended my childhood is over and this sort
of transformational nature of the event
was not conveyed to me through most this
movies I've seen you also clearly wanted
to pick the camps as factories that they
are factories and they refer to the dead
as pieces that it is a factory that is
producing something what is producing
our dead bodies with that part of your
kind of overall design in terms of how
you wanted to depict the work there that
these were factories and they were
engaged in the business of death
absolutely and they were factories and
and that we wanted to preserve the sort
of realistic approach based on facts and
try to not to make a fail of filming
drama out of every situation you know
that and that's I think also something
very interesting is that there's no not
always the drama that we imagine but
still it's it's the middle of of hell so
there's a sort of you know routine and
this is that that's established for
these people even the Sonderkommando
members have a routine at some point
they became they become machines because
they have to it's as they are in a
traumatized state but the this this
place the concentration camps were you
know we're buildings and there will be
people in in there so we we we just
wanted to you know to to have a raw
experience of it and not say we're we're
in another place another planet we're
it's here and now and and and try to
find the ways and cinema to translate
that what is that like when you're on
set when you're building your set of a
death camp when you're in Budapest
creating from the ground up I mean it
was a converted Factory right what does
that feel like as a filmmaker as an
artist to create something that is both
profane and sacred at the same time it's
it's extremely uncomfortable I I visited
with this production designer and then
the Scimitar for the sets but the sets
really looked they were in one
you know interior part was in one one
piece and the exterior was also kind of
in one piece so in and and everything is
it wasn't one piece and we had the
feeling of being in a real place so I I
said to them we both we just built
ourselves a crematorium and that is that
is really you know it opens a
perspective that's dead scary and but
but actually it is sacred you know in a
way it becomes sacred and and we and and
I don't have a visual memory of the
shoot in a way I didn't look I are the
only eye that that that would remain as
the cameras eye
I don't remember well you know
undershoot I just remembered the angles
do you remember it and what was it like
as an actor because your character is
probably trying so hard not to see what
is going around him he's averting his
eyes through so much to the movie but as
an actor you're obviously seeing what's
around you did you find that kind of an
odd predicament in terms of what you
were witnessing and where put you as an
actor on set I try not to really I did
my best to remain in my inner reality
because it did after all this was a
movie making the shooting was going on
lots of instructions things and they I
really did not you know socialized in
the breaks I was not you know try try to
really just be saw you know and it was
it sort of on-and-off thing for me you
know I I went I went home I didn't
living in New York City I had my family
to the production rented me a room and I
really was in a solitary place you know
situation and I think that that's what I
needed